el 15 de febrero de 2022 la ciudad de
petrópolis fue golpeada por las peores
lluvias de su historia conocida por su
Palacio Imperial construido en 1845 por
el emperador Pedro segundo es un lugar
emblemático para los brasileños
[Aplausos]
aquel día llovió más de lo que se
esperaba para todo el mes en tan solo 3
horas cayeron 250 mm de agua los
deslizamientos dejaron 235 muertos
desde entonces Muchas de las 15.000
personas afectadas por esta Tempestad
precisan de ayuda para comer
en esas canastas hay arroz frijoles
aceite harina de yuca harina de maíz y
pasta macajón
normalmente para una familia de cuatro
personas alcanza un mes
esta ong nació para hacer frente a la
emergencia y nunca más paró de ayudar
hoy sigue entregando un millar de
canastas solidarias por mes la
topografía de la ciudad no es apropiada
porque hay muchos cerros
Entonces cuando las personas construyen
en estas áreas
abren caminos para que el agua pase y
destruya todo
hoy Carolina lleva las provisiones a
shakara Flora una comunidad que fue
totalmente devastada por las lluvias
[Aplausos]
en este barrio encaramado la montaña 23
personas perdieron la vida
el rastro de la destrucción todavía Es
evidente en una ciudad donde el 30% de
los habitantes binaria de riesgo por la
falta Crónica de vivienda tras la
tragedia el gobierno local ofreció un
subsidio para alquilar un piso en un
barrio más seguro pero muchas personas
dependen de esta asociación para poner
un plato de comida en la mesa
esta mujer perdió a su hija de 18 años
un bebé su cuñada embarazada en total
seis miembros de su familia y un puesto
callejero de comida su único sustento Mi
mayor problema ahora es el trabajo
Yo me esfuerzo trabajo como limpiadora
hago pequeños trabajos
estoy consiguiendo sobrevivir Perdí todo
pero gané nuevos amigos personas que me
amparan
cada vez que les llamo que les digo que
estoy en apuros consigo una ayuda
inmediata
este otro perro se desmoronó por
completo llevándose por delante a más de
90 personas un año después han empezado
las obras para reforzar las laderas pero
todavía queda mucho por hacer
Valeria perdió a varios amigos en el
mayor desastre Ambiental de petrópolis
desde su balcón vio atónita el
Apocalipsis en pocos minutos todo esto
se vino abajo yo sabía que allí atrás en
frente a aquella ladera había una
escuela
Yo sabía que aquel día había clases
demoró no pasó ni un minuto y oímos un
ruido aún más ensordecedor
como muchos vecinos está traumatizada
por las lluvias y necesita remedios para
lidiar con la ansiedad ayer parecía que
iba a llover
en estos días todo el mundo estaba
aterrorizado pero de noche allí consigue
dormir
aquella imagen Siempre vuelva a la
cabeza
en esta ciudad de 300.000 habitantes es
muy común ver a obreros arreglando las
calzadas cada vez que la lluvia aprieta
el equipo de protección civil entra en
alerta desde estas pantallas controlan
en tiempo real si los ríos se desbordan
el ayuntamiento ha creado un protocolo
de evacuación y varios refugios ya que
es imposible realojar a los millares de
personas que viven en lugares peligrosos
toda la población tiene que ser
entrenada
paralelas este es nuestro mayor desafío
paralelamente a las obras públicas
los ciudadanos de petrópolis tienen que
entender que viven en una ciudad de
riesgo
los expertos coinciden en que esta
tragedia medioambiental es un reflejo
del cambio climático Y peor aún puede
repetirse en cualquier momento es algo
que asusta a los turistas e impide
recuperar las 500.000 visitas anuales de
antes de la pandemia
petrópolis vive básicamente del turismo
la bajada del turismo aquí significa una
bajada de la economía y Por ende de las
políticas públicas
entonces recibimos menos inversiones En
la ciudad
si hay menos turistas se resiente toda
la red hotelera el comercio y eso tiene
un impacto enorme para nosotros
aquel fatídico 15 de febrero un metro de
agua destruyó parcialmente el jardín
diseñado por Pedro segundo un grupo de
turistas Tuvo que pasar la noche del
palacio sin poder volver a su hotel hoy
la ciudad lucha para curar sus heridas y
recuperar la normalidad